A
CALLY.
THA CLIP.
WATCH THIS. HELLO
>> FEELINGR NOW.
BETTER, BUT AT LEAST NOW THERE'S
SOME JUSTICE.
>>.
NO I THINK GOING
TORT TO CH NOW.
>> YES. E HAVE T IT NOW. Y.
>> IT'S .
YOU'RE AN INCREDIBLE FAMILY.
I HEO PUT MY
MSUND YOU.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING EVERY SECOND
OF THIS, THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
ALL OF US.
JUST W SO RELIEV -- ON
ALL THREE.
AND IT REALLY IMPORTANT.ANXIOUSU
AL
WE'RE GOING TO LET A LOT MORE
DONE.
TO DO A LOT.
WE'RE GOING TO STAY AT IT UNTIL
WE GETT DONE.
>> HOPEFULLY THI MOMENTUM FOR T.
>> YOUOT IT,.
AND T MORE.
NOT JUSTT.T MORE.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.IS
DEALING WITH GC
RACISM.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO FEEAS
STRONGLY AS I DO.
SAY SOMETHING. ENT, S TO
>> OKAY.
>> I'M STH
COURAGE, YOURMMITMENT, YOTREN E
AMERICA
YOUR FAMILY ARE REAL LEADETHIS .
IN GEORGNAME AND MEMORY, WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
LEGACYS INTACT AND THAT
HIST A
MOMENT AND KNOW THIS IS AN T.
YOU ACSOUCH, UR FAMILY, BUTE RE
BELIEVE THAT WITH YOURND PRESID
THATHAVE IN THE WHITE HO TO
GOOD OF THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
Y BR ALL GET READWHEN WE DO I
,  WE'RE GOING THOLDO
IT. NK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> M WITH ME.
>> YOU.
SAID,  TO HINKING ABOUT YOU.[ I
CHANGE THE WORLD.
>> GOD.G TO CHANGE W
>> YOU TELL HER WHAT I
REMIND HER SHE'S -INAUDIBLE ]
'S COMING TO SEE YOUMR
PRESIDT.[ LAUGHTER ]
NKOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MR.
GOD BLESS YOU.
.
>> TNK, MRPRESIDENT.
>> THEREOU.
VES NO
COMING IN FR
OTHER REPRESENTATIVEOF
FAMILY
YOU SEE THEMHE.
WE JUST HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDEN T
DY
THEY CALLED BEN CRUMTOEF AND THS
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> SAY HIS NAME!
>> GEOFLOYD!
>> GEORGE FLOYD!
>> HIS NAME!FLOYD!
>> HIS
>> GEORGE OY
>> SAYE!
>> GEORGE FLOYD! HIS NAME!
>> GEOFL H
ORE WE S ANYTH WE'RE
G TO HAVA  WANWET TO
SITE, WHEN BEN CRUMP CALD,E
REMEMBERED HOW ERI
SITE.SS S
THFAMILY CS
FAMILYFOR
THE LA 1, WATCHING
THISEO GR AN A.
THIS FAMILT KNOWINWHECAUSE S
THE INNTH WOULD NOHAVE HAPPENEDH
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEITH ELLISON
TOS SE.
>>
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AND KEITH ELLISON FGH
PUT TOGETHER A TEAM THAT MADE
THIS POSSIBLE.THIS IS E FIRST TT
ITC
ICERAS BEET
CONVICD,MUS THE FIRST TIME IA LG
THREE COUNTS, IL
THREE.
WE DON'T FIND PLEASURE IN THIS.
T CELEBRATE
GOING TO JAIL.
RA
ALIVE.
CELEBRE,
E UNPEOPLE, WHIT
BLACK, SOME , MANY
THAT ARE HERE GHCHED
AND KEPT MARCHING AND KEPT
MANY OF THEM LOOKED DOWN O BUT
LET THISIE
AND THIS ISSURANCE TO THEMAT DO
WAR ANDNOW, WE'RE IS NOT OVEST
GOIN HEAL WITH THEL OF DAUNTE WS
SAME COUNTY, TAREA
WE STILL HAVE CASES TO,
BUT THIS GIVES US THE ENERGY TF.
AND WE ARED  WE'RE
FEDE GD  FHT WE MAKE
JUSTICE MUST BE
LAW.
THANK THAT WERE
INVOLVED, ESPECIALLY T
ATEY THE
THWE WANTO T
CAME OUT OS HOUS T
MET WITH FAMILY TORNEY THERE ANL
NEVER FOD TO  DAUGHTER THAT I
YOU SAY LD.
WELL, WE CAN NOW TELL GE'S
RIGHT.AN THE
CHANGING OF E WORL.
BUT BEFORE ANYTHING, W
FIRST WANTO  AND THANK
HE HADWE BELIEVEN A GO CAN EN G
THE RYM AND BRIN
CONSCIENCE AND BRING TRUTH.
ANATTHK
STRENGTH.ING GODIVE THEM
WHEREVER THEARE GHT, WE
WANT THE BROKE DOWN
INHEN WE HEARD THE
VERDICT.
WEADO HOLD EACD
HUG INRS, BECAUSE TOO
NIGHTS WVE OFOR DECADES,PE NIGH
ANOTHER DAY.N FOR
WE BRING IT FOR THE ERICEP GOIN